une autre personnalité de l'entreprise a été
ciblée par le groupe d'activistes Eco l'
est nous avons besoin de quelqu'un pour entrer dans l'
est me choisiriez-vous j'ai inattendu
être inattendu est le seul avantage
qui compte Robert McCabe m'a appelé
lui-même dans un mois je veux
savoir  l'identité de chaque personne qui a
empoisonné sa cocaïne à la recherche de l'étiquette de l'
Est j'ai entendu dire que l'Est n'existe pas
qui est-elle la bienvenue à l'est Sarah
a quelque chose de prévu pour nous quand il
s'agit d'enfreindre la loi la plupart des gens
ne peuvent pas le supporter je  peut le faire allons-y
allons-y ce groupe est engagé et
ils sont devant nous
un œil pour œil ne peut pas être plus ne peut pas
être moins il y a des conséquences qui s'y
rattachent c'est bien mais ne
soyez pas résolu
je peux '  ne continuez pas comme ça, ce serait plus
facile car nous ne ressentions pas le besoin de nous battre,
nous laissons aller quels sont les
dommages potentiels graves
qu'est-ce que vous attendiez que ces rubis
indolores vont rester calmes ne peuvent pas vous retenir